I'm telling you I interview hundreds of
people on this I mean for sure even
Christians as Sinners Christian women
have a worse reputation than regular
women right men have a part to play for
example
for example more than 50 of men in the
church masturbate and watch pornography
so what does that say about men
it's not a case of gender it's a case of
humanity it's okay you know what I'll
probably I'll tell you the porn thing
it's so funny because we don't look at
why are they watching porn we always are
immediately blaming the men but we don't
look at why a lot of Christian women
don't sleep with their husbands and they
weaponize sex against their husbands so
a quarter of marriages are sexless
that's one and then two two a lot of the
men in the church are sexless because
they're Sims and the women all the
guitar guys on stage you know they're
pulling